Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you’re watching
the Today I Found Out Youtube channel.
In the video today, we’re looking at why
the way most people draw hearts looks nothing
like a real heart.
The heart symbol is one of the single most
enduring and widely recognised symbols in
modern culture.
But where did it come from?
Something like the familiar heart symbol goes
back many thousands of years.
Specifically, several pieces of pottery going
back as far as 3000BC clearly show the unmistakable
symbol.
However, in these instances, the symbol is
noted to be a simplification of either a fig
or ivy leaf, not a crude representation of
the human heart, and seemingly, at least initially,
not having anything to do with love.
Fast-forwarding through history and we find
many cultures using a similar symbol, such
as depicted in Grecian, Cretian, Minoan, Mycean,
Roman and Corinthian pottery, along with many
others.
In these instances, again, the symbol doesn't
appear to be representative of a heart, but
of various leaves.
For example, the early vine leaf imagery in
Greek culture was mostly used to represent
Dionysus, the god of wine, fertility, and
ecstasy, among other things.
For a more straightforward example of the
ivy leaf imagery having a double, suggestive
meaning, in the city of Ephesus around fourth
century A.D, the symbol was used to represent
a brothel.
As ivy is quite long-lived and hardy, it was
also prominently seen on early Greek and Roman
graves.
Interestingly, entirely independent of the
Greeks and Romans, Buddhists also came to
use a symbol similar to that of the drawn
heart.
However, in their culture, it was representative
of a fig leaf, which came to symbolise enlightenment.
However, just because these very similar early
symbols strongly resemble the modern symbol
for the heart, doesn't necessarily mean this
is where the modern symbol came from and we,
unfortunately, lack much in the way of direct
evidence to trace its early lineage.
As such, it has also been proposed that it
derived from a different, now extinct, plant
known as, "silphium", which was used in ancient
times as a very effective form of birth control,
among many other uses.
The trade of silphium was so lucrative that
Cyrene, the town it was grown in, actually
put it on their money.
Along with its obvious links with a form of
love, the plant's seed pod was stylised in
ancient times as what we can now recognise
as akin to the heart symbol.
Whether these various leaves or seed pod had
anything to do with the subsequent symbol
directly, it is generally thought describing
the human heart as looking like certain leaves
may have had something to do with it.
You see, though Arabic and other doctors of
earlier periods had made leaps and bounds
in anatomical study, during the middle ages,
much of this was lost or suppressed by the
Church.
And with autopsies being outlawed, many were
forced to rely on the early descriptions of
these doctors and nothing else.
These descriptions tended to describe the
heart in one of two ways, looking something
like a conifer cone in overall shape or looking
something like an inverted leaf, with the
stem as the arterial branching.
As for direct evidence, appearing in a 13th
century French manuscript and written by an
unknown author, a simple romance tale called
"Roman de la poire" (Romance of the pear)
is now famous for featuring one of the the
earliest known images of the heart in a metaphorical
sense, where a man hands his heart to his
lover.
Its shape is likened to that of a conifer
cone, in keeping with the known medical literature
of the time.
Around this same time in the 13th century,
the royal banner of the kings of Denmark prominently
depicted the heart symbol.
In the early 14th century, we also see yet
another conifer-cone shaped heart where Giotto
de Bondone depicts a heart being giving to
Christ in a painting at the Scrovegni Chapel.
From here, numerous others began using this
same basic symbol, at first with the point
commonly on top, and then switched to pointing
down like today around the 15th century.
During this same period, the indentation in
the fat side of the heart symbol started to
appear more and more frequently, perhaps mimicking
the look of certain types of leaves as mentioned
and as many have theorised, or perhaps not.
Whatever the case, during the next few hundred
years, several things happened that saw the
heart symbol's popularity explode.
Ironically, though the Church had played a
large role in people being unaware of what
an actual human heart looked like, it also
was integral in the spreading of the heart
symbol.
Specifically, the so called "Sacred Heart
of Jesus" was supposedly seen in a vision
by one, Saint Margaret Mary Alacoque in 1673.
Physically, this Sacred Heart is remarkably
similar to the modern heart symbol, though
generally depicted surrounded by thorns and
sometimes depicted on fire.
The Catholic Church used this symbol extensively
in the subsequent centuries.
However, as previously noted, by that point
the symbol and its use to depict a human heart
had already been well known and commonly used
by artists and others for a few centuries.
It was even used by Protestant Reformation
leader Martin Luther when he oversaw the development
of his coat of arms, "Luther Rose", in 1519,
over a century and a half before Saint Margaret's
vision.
Luther had this to say about the design of
his coat of arms in a letter written in 1530:
“...I shall answer most amiably and tell
you my original thoughts and reason about
why my seal is a symbol of my theology.
The first should be a black cross in a heart,
which retains its natural color, so that I
myself would be reminded that faith in the
Crucified saves us.
'For one who believes from the heart will
be justified' (Romans 10:10).
Although it is indeed a black cross, which
mortifies and which should also cause pain,
it leaves the heart in its natural color.
It does not corrupt nature, that is, it does
not kill but keeps alive.
'The just shall live by faith' (Romans 1:17)
but by faith in the Crucified.
Such a heart should stand in the middle of
a white rose, to show that faith gives joy,
comfort, and peace...”
So contrary to what is often said, Saint Margaret
Mary Alacoque's vision was not the origin
of the symbol as representing a heart, but
certainly helped popularise it with its widespread
use by the Catholic Church after this.
The other important thing that happened to
help popularise the symbol, and that also
predated the Sacred Heart vision, is the late
15th century introduction, and later spreading,
of the French card suits, Cœurs (Hearts),
Carreaux (Diamonds), Trefles (Clubs) and Piques
(Spades).
In the end, though religious pressure on the
medical world waned in later centuries and
anatomical knowledge was eventually spread
far and wide, the sheer amount of artistic,
poetic and commercial attention given to the
iconic heart symbol not only saw it survive,
but thrive as symbol for both the human heart
and love.
Despite that love doesn't originate in, nor
does the symbol look much like, the human
heart, from the looks of things, the drawn
heart representing these things is not about
to change anytime soon.